hey you guys welcome back once again to
flickers of fear got a little bit of an
obscure one for you today but i'm
actually really glad that i got to
rewatch this one so
i feel like in the annals of
serial killer dumb if you want to call
it that
the name john reginald christie is
probably not all that familiar to
americans i would say
but he is absolutely notorious in the uk
like one of the best known serial
killers over there at least as that was
my perception
so this guy was just kind of like he
seemed very mild-mannered um his friends
called him reg
and he actually killed uh at least eight
people maybe more uh in the 1940s and he
sort of stashed their bodies in and
around his notting hill uh flat which is
you know in london if you didn't know
now he got hanged for his crimes in 1953
and his case is notable
not only because of the number of
victims and like the kind of [ __ ] up
way that it happened like in that he was
stashing the bodies in the house and
stuff
but there was also the suspicion that
christie might have been a necrophile so
there was that as well
but there was also like a big to-do
because a very very likely innocent man
was actually sent to the gallows was
hanged in 1950 for two murders which
it's almost certain that john christie
committed so in 1961 uh there was a
british journalist named ludovic kennedy
and he kind of specialized in talking
about miscarriages of justice like
writing about that so he wrote a book
called ten rillington place
and in that book he laid out like all
the proof all the arguments and stuff
like that that john christie had
actually manipulated uh this innocent
man that i mentioned earlier who was
actually this working class uh welsh guy
named timothy evans into basically
taking the fall for the murders of his
wife and baby daughter
now like i said evans got hanged for
this even they're pretty sure nowadays
he didn't do it now he got posthumously
pardoned in 1966
but evans's wrongful conviction and
execution was actually one of the really
big things that led to the uk abolishing
the death penalty because this was just
like such a massive deal so in 1970 uh
they made a film adaptation essentially
of the book ten burlington police
although they changed i think the book
title is like spells out ten en but the
movie title is just 10 the number but
that's pretty much the only difference
now when it was released in 1971 um i
think it was released in britain in 1970
and then maybe it came out later because
i've seen like two dates
it kind of got a little bit mixed
reviews not bad reviews but some people
thought i don't know i i just kind of
feel like oh they didn't go enough into
you know the backstory like john
christie backs or anything like that but
i'll kind of get into that in a little
bit but yeah so the reviews were kind of
mixed at first but then as time has gone
on because you know this is a 50 year
old movie now i feel like the critical
reassessment has been overwhelmingly
positive and it absolutely should be
because this movie is amazing
now i first saw this movie probably it's
got to be like at least 20 years or so
ago now at the time like back in the
late 90s early 2000s i was going back
and forth to the uk a lot because i used
to be uh married to a british person so
we would go back and forth to wales in
particular and i was also really
fascinated by british movies as well as
british serial killers so i like read a
lot of books about them so john christie
was actually very familiar to me so
that's one of the reasons that i wanted
to see this movie all that time ago and
i absolutely absolutely loved it now
it's not
it's i know it's a weird thing to say
because it's not like a real pleasant
film to watch i'm not gonna lie it has
this like real eerie
this quiet eeriness to it and it's
really like
the quality of it it's just very very
enthralling like it just kind of pulls
you right in it's very drab and
claustrophobic but there's something
that you can't really like look away
from and it's just i don't know just the
whole vibe of this movie is just really
really great so the movie was actually
directed by richard fleischer who i'm
sure that i have brought up at some
point in the past now his resume doesn't
really suggest somebody that would be
the right person for this type of
material or like the way this movie came
out he was kind of always known more as
a successful money-making director
rather than like an artistic one or an
auteur or whatever he kind of made of
movies all over the [ __ ] place but
most of his movies were actually really
successful uh he made some movies in the
60s he made 20 000 leagues under the sea
for example uh dr doolittle from 1967
tora toratora uh he made soylent green
with charlton heston conan the destroyer
red sonja and amityville 3d which we
just covered like i think on one of the
mat day shows not too long ago he
directed that as well so like i said his
resume's got all over the place but i
have to say he works an absolute
miracle with this movie 10 relington
police he just kind of brings so much
gripping drama out of basically just a
handful of characters and essentially a
single location it doesn't really expand
outward too much from the house where it
all took place
incidentally uh some parts of this movie
were shot in the actual house where the
real murders occurred uh the real house
was actually you know the address being
temper linked in place obviously it was
actually like torn down not too long
after this film was made now other bits
of it like the exteriors and stuff they
actually shot it on the same street but
you know it's like a couple houses down
or something like that i think most of
the interiors though were shot on a
sound stage
um the movie too also uses
uh actual testimony and dialogue like
from the official court records from the
john christie case uh wherever that was
possible so at the beginning of the
movie it's 1944
and we see a woman who's arriving at 10
rilington police
so she gets ushered in by this kind of
creepy looking dude a very balding
soft-spoken spectacle-wearing
[ __ ] actually played by richard
attenborough and he's so great in this
he's just so like priscilly menacing i
guess is like the way that he put it
which is kind of like what the real john
christie was like so basically what the
situation here is is that john christie
has told this woman that he has some
kind of medical training and he can help
her out with her chronic bronchitis
so he makes a big show of making this
tonic that has to be inhaled like a
vapor
and uh using but like he does a little
switcheroo and using like actually the
house's gas like the the stove that
comes into the stove and everything like
that he actually gasses her either dead
or unconscious and then after that it's
implied that he rapes her strangles her
with a rope like to finish her off and
buries her in the back garden so all
that established uh the movie then jumps
ahead to 1949 and we sort of get into
like the meat of the story
so john christie and his wife ethel are
subletting out the top two floors of
their three-story row house
now apparently there's an older
gentleman named mr kitchener who lives
on the second floor although we never
see him he's always he's was in the
hospital or something at the time
but the top floor is still to rent
there's like a little sign up in the
window
so then enter the evans family uh tim
who is like you know the dad and the
husband uh he's actually played by john
hurt who got a bafta nomination for this
movie
um his wife beryl who's played by judy
geesen and their baby daughter geraldine
now tim uh is very poorly educated and
illiterate uh like i said he's a
welshman i really do like uh john hurt's
welsh accent in this it just like kind
of took me back and one of his big
things is that even though he's not the
sharpest knife in the drawer
he really gets off on
telling tall tales about his fabulously
wealthy relatives like he's like his dad
is an italian count or something like
that also like how awesome he is with
women and it's like yeah i've got all
these birds does this and that and the
other thing and it's all [ __ ] but
it's like he's very he's one of those
kind of [ __ ] yeah now when he
goes to look at the flat like and john
christie is showing them the flat which
is you know okay but it's kind of like
scuzzy looking um and he's like oh well
this flat it's it's okay but you know
the one we had to come from was like
much better than this one but you know
we just had to move for whatever like he
comes up with some like lame kind of
excuse but john christie pretty much you
know say what you will about him but he
wasn't dumb and he pretty much like
clocked immediately like this guy's
insecurities and his prejudices and he
says oh well if you don't want it that's
okay but there was this irish family
that was in here looking at it and they
want it really bad and so tim is just
like oh no we can't have them have it
we'll take it we'll take it and i mean
it's very clear that he's desperate for
pretty much any place to stay on his
meager salary despite saying oh the
money's not an issue i have all the
money my family's rich and stuff like
that which like i said is complete
[ __ ] so the family moves in and it's
obvious right from the start that
christy has designs on the pretty young
barrel the wife
he kind of takes to popping into her
flat like uninvited like hey brought you
a cup of tea i was just making some you
know automatic that it's like and he's
saying stuff like oh if you ever need
anybody to talk to like i know you know
i know how stuff is and blah blah blah
and so he's like lending her a shoulder
to cry and stuff like that now beryl is
intensely creeped out by this dude as
you would be but basically he's her
landlord and he hasn't really done
anything overtly alarming so she just
kind of
grins and bears it she doesn't want to
piss him off or anything like that
because she knows that they're kind of
in
financial
you know dire straits and they don't
really have any place else to go however
uh her and tim have a pretty volatile
relationship
and it so happens that not too long
after they move in she finds out that
she's pregnant again and then she starts
taking pills to try to induce an
abortion because there's just no way
that they can afford another baby
already because like i said they still
have one that's you know just like a
toddler still
so after she tells tim about this he
basically goes off on a horrible like
drunken tear he's like screaming and he
starts smacking her around and all this
other kind of stuff and basically it
wakes the whole street up right that's
because it's like the middle of the
night because he just comes home from
the pub
so john christie of course is very put
out by all this commotion
and he's basically like threatening to
throw them out if they cause any more
disturbances but christy also uses this
rift in the evans's marriage to kind of
wangle his way closer to barrel
um he basically gets her to admit that
her and tim were fighting over the
decision uh you know or her decision
she's trying to like end the pregnancy
and he's so he like senses an
opportunity he comes up with a story
that he's like oh before the war
um i started to train as a doctor but
then i got into an accident and i
couldn't continue like on with school
but i've assisted in at least 100
abortions i totally know how to do it um
and in fact i'd be quite happy to take
care of your little problem for you
completely free um as long as you keep
your mouth shut about it so i don't get
arrested now beryl is grateful for this
and she's like yes please like please
take care of it as soon as possible and
uh tim doesn't like it at first but
they're eventually able to talk him into
it um you know he's still kind of
reluctant but he's like yeah you're
right we can't really afford another one
blah blah so john christie though uh
taking advantage of tim's illiteracy and
his kind of like simple-mindedness like
i said he wasn't really the brightest um
he pretty much snows him with all of
this medical knowledge that he has um
and
because he's of course planning to kill
barrel
he makes sure like before he does the
procedure uh to kind of plant the seed
like before it takes place he's like oh
you know it's i'm i'm good at this but
one in ten women you know die during
this uh procedure that i'm gonna do and
he also throws in some very subtle like
victim blaming in there like hey you
know if you guys had come to me like
about getting an abortion earlier i
could have performed it with absolutely
no risk of death at all but you know you
waited too long but i can still do it
but you know it might go wrong i'm just
it probably won't but it's all fine
now poor confused tim uh absolutely
falls for it like i said
not the sharpest tool in the shed so the
day for john christie's uh planned crime
arrives but
at this point and this is pretty much
what really happened like you know this
stuck pretty close to like the actual
[ __ ] that happened
so it's almost like this real grotesque
like comedy of errors
there's a whole bunch of things that
like conspire to prevent him from doing
his thing like he's trying to get his
wife out of the house blah blah so he
tells her oh you know i'm not feeling
too well today my back and everything
but she did have like health problems
and stuff can you like go down to my
office and tell them that i'm not going
to be in today and she's like
[ __ ] why don't you just call
them he's like no no um you can't just
call them because there's oh there's all
these papers or contracts or something
like that and they'll want these um so
please like go down to my episode he's
trying to like just get rid of her so
finally she's like jesus christ fine
okay so wife is gone you know that's
fine and then just as he's gathering his
little murder kit that he keeps like
locked in this first aid cabinet thing
um you know he's got all that in the bag
and he's got like the tea and everything
like that he's just about going up the
stairs to beryl's apartment a pair of
contractors show up at the front door
and are like hey remember how you
complain been complaining to the council
about that [ __ ] up roof on your
outhouse we're here to fix it and he's
just like [ __ ] me and then you know what
i mean and so he's like well should i
uh you know everything was perfect and i
was really ready to do this but maybe i
shouldn't do it because now all these
[ __ ] [ __ ] would be trooping
through the house but they said no no
it's like it's all just the outbuildings
we're not gonna be
in your hair and
basically like barrel is coming down
like are we gonna do this today or what
like i really need to to get this done
so he's just like okay well i guess
we're just gonna go on with it and i'll
just have to be really careful
so uh spoiler alert like i said um you
know i i kind of feel like not too bad
about spoiling because it's actually
based on a real case so it's not like
it's any surprise like what happened but
uh poor barrel uh gets killed gassed
raped and strangled uh in her apartment
on the floor of her apartment just like
the woman back in 1944. now after the
deed is done there's another kind of
thing where her friend who i think her
name is alice or something like that
where her friend like comes by and is
like banging on the door and like she
can't get in and uh christy is in there
going oh [ __ ] like i'm gonna get caught
and all this other kind of stuff but
eventually like the friend goes away so
he just kind of gets on with it so when
tim comes home from work christy tells
him uh i'm sorry but the worst has
happened beryl died during the operation
now tim is just absolutely shocked and
he's just inconsolable like he has no
idea what he's gonna do now
and christy like kind of twists the
knife in further
by again like blaming hey if you'd come
to me earlier like this wouldn't have
happened and maybe it was those pills
she'd been taking to you know try to
induce the abortion before maybe that
[ __ ] things up it wasn't me you know
what i mean i told you that this could
happen and all this other stuff
and then through a series of seemingly
logical
arguments
christy is actually able to convince tim
who like i said is
kind of dumb
that both of them should not call the
police absolutely because we just need
to dispose of barrel's body down the
manhole out front like into the drain
because if we report her death to the
police then christy says then i'll get
in trouble for performing the abortion
because it's illegal and tim will get
arrested for knowing and consenting to
the procedure which would make him an
accessory he also low-key
threatens tim
that hey if you don't go along with my
plan
i'm gonna tell the police that you did
it and he's like and i'll have all these
witnesses backing me up because
everybody along the street has heard you
guys arguments and like you slapping her
around and stuff like that so no one's
gonna think it's crazy that you actually
killed her so he like low-key threatens
him with that as well so suffice it to
say that it all goes very very badly for
poor stupid tim
who skips town at christy's suggestion
leaving his baby daughter behind
supposedly in the care of a childless
couple that christy knows
in reality i hate to have to inform you
uh christy strangles the baby pretty
much immediately after tim is gone
now tim actually goes to i think martha
tidville in wales uh where some of his
relatives are
and when he gets there
he um is basically like he feels bad
like after a little while like he starts
you know his conscience starts to bother
him so he goes to the police there and
reports but he makes up like all these
other stories like at first he's trying
not to get christy in trouble so he says
well i killed my wife and i put her down
the manhole and then like the police go
and look in the manhole but she's not in
there because unbeknownst to him christy
has put the body someplace else that he
didn't know about because he told
you know he told him i'm gonna put her
down the manhole but he didn't actually
he hit her someplace else now when he
actually confesses and all this other
stuff they inform him it's like oh you
killed your baby daughter as well and he
is horrified because obviously the baby
was still alive when he left and christy
killed the baby um so now he's getting
blamed for that as well
and he realizes that john christie did
all this stuff and is now like trying to
pin it on him
now tim actually does um yeah like i
said through a series of things where uh
you know he ends up signing a confession
because he was just like devastated and
he didn't know what he was gonna do and
then like he tried to come up with this
other story where he was trying to not
get christy into it but then when he
realized that his life was on the line
then he started telling about what
christie really did and [ __ ] like that
so they kind of think that he's maybe
not that trustworthy because he keeps
coming up with all these other stories
because like i said again not really all
that bright
so he actually does go on trial and he
attempts to tell the court what really
happened that john christie did all this
and tried to like pin it on him but john
christie who is actually testifying
gives very very calm rational testimony
that eventually ends up like convincing
the court convincing the jurors that tim
is the one that killed his wife and
daughter like i said nobody knows about
the other women so far that uh john
christie killed so to them it just looks
like a domestic violence kind of thing
so tim gets executed he gets hanged in
1950
and christy is free for another three
years i mean he doesn't do all that like
he ends up pretty much like homeless or
what in the uk they would call a dos
house so i guess like a workhouse or
whatever but he ends up there um because
he can't afford to pay for the house
anymore um but yeah so he's free another
three years after tim gets hanged for
his murders and during those three years
he actually kills four more women
including his wife ethel after she
starts to become suspicious of him and
kind of like low-key threatens that she
might like i don't think she like says
hey i'm going to the cops but she's
basically like i'm pretty sure like i
know what you did kind of thing and
she's gonna leave and then he kills her
so he actually didn't get found out
until a new tenant moved into 10
burlington place and accidentally
uncovered like this crawl space behind a
kitchen wall that he had like sort of
covered up the wallpaper and [ __ ] that
had a whole bunch of corpses in there so
like i said he was walking around free
for three [ __ ] years so while the
subject matter obviously of 10
rellington plays is
very unpleasant and this is it's like
just a bone bone-chilling story not only
because of the serial killer obviously
but because this poor
dumb dope like got
hanged for two murders he didn't commit
you know what i mean it's horrifying but
despite that i mean the all the all the
performances in this are fantastic
particularly richard attenborough and
john hurt and you know the their
performances really make this like just
a mesmerizing hypnotic kind of movie to
watch i mean it's a grim it's hor it's
horrific it's maddening it's tragic
but you really can't help getting drawn
into the story even if you're familiar
with the details of the real case which
actually i was you know to some extent i
especially like the way that the movie
treats the material it's not like
exploitative at all it's not gory it's
not lurid it's nothing like that it's
very very
uh subdued now
as i said it doesn't really give a lot
of insight into john christie's
pathology or the reasons why he did what
he did which i think was kind of like
the main criticism that it got when it
came out
but to me that made the movie creepier
like more disturbing because you're
you're basically seeing john christie
the way his potential victims would have
seen him um not knowing anything about
his history or his proclivities or you
know what was gonna happen like what was
going on in his head
so the fact that you're just kind of
seeing him from that perspective to me
like makes it a lot creepier so if
you're at all into british cinema and
you know sort of serial killer movies
that are more
kind of understated examinations of the
case rather than real lurid gory like
over-the-top kind of serial killer
movies then this is one of the best
movies of that type that you're ever
likely to see and it's one that really
doesn't seem to get a lot of attention
sadly so i mean check it out it's
definitely definitely worth it i
actually watched it on amazon prime it's
on the free to me section on amazon
prime but i'm sure you can find it
elsewhere as well and that will do it
for this flickers of fear i will see you
guys on the next one bye